saviez vous que pendant la pandémie vous
pouvez obtenir une réduction de vos
primes d'assurance auto mais dans
certains cas il faut le demander la
réduction peut aller jusqu'à 25 % de la
prime et ça peut aller jusqu'à trois
mois tout dépendant de l'assureur
remarquez que c'est un cadeau qui est
facile à faire parce que comme les gens
utilisent moins leur voiture
le risque diminue pour les assureurs
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
on ne vous offre pas de réduction de
votre prime d'assurance habitation
parce que comme on est dans nos maisons
de façon permanente depuis des semaines
le risque ne diminue pas pour les
assureurs alors pour la prime
d'assurance auto maintenant certains
assureurs vont vous offrir une réduction
automatique
c'est le cas par exemple de ssq
assurance la capitale l'unique
industrielle alliance all-stars
pembridge et paf comme par exemple par
contre si vous êtes assurés avec
desjardins promutuel intact assurance et
heller direct td assurance
là c'est à vous de faire la demande et
vous devez le faire vite parce que
certains imposent une date limite
sachez aussi que les réductions ne
s'applique pas aux motos ni ouvert et si
vous passez votre temps libre à faire de
la livraison de nourriture avec votre
auto personnel parlez-en avec votre
assureur
alors ça c'est le volet réduction mais
plusieurs assureurs offrent aussi le
report de paiement votre prime peut être
reporté pour une période allant jusqu'à
trois mois et bonne nouvelle c'est sans
intérêt si les paiements sont reportés
ça veut dire que vous allez devoir
éventuellement les rembourser là encore
les assureurs font preuve de souplesse
vous pouvez les rembourser en faisant de
plus petits paiements sur une plus
longue période ou par plus gros
versements c'est à vous de faire votre
arrangement avec votre assureur
et sachez aussi que ce report de
paiement est offert autant pour
l'assurance auto que l'assurance
habitation